The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
For those of you
who don't read The Times
back to front every day,
there was a terrific
section that
relates to today's lecture.
It didn't give me nice
cases as Don's did,
but the headline captures a lot
of what goes on in the section,
and a lot of what
we'll talk about today.
The headline is, "Fuel to burn--
now what?"
So I'm going to talk about
shale and its implications,
and what it's done to
the energy universe
in the last couple of years.
But first, I've got
some unfinished business
from last time, a couple of
questions I didn't answer.
Prosper asked whether
anybody was still
making coal gas in the
old-fashioned, manufactured
gas, town gas, heat it
and use the results style.
And I couldn't find anybody.
I looked around.
I did the usual kind
of web crawling.
But what I did find is a lot of
people that have made and are
making gas from wood.
This is a reactor
being sold by a company
in South Africa that's sold
it to a number of locations--
wood pellets to make gas,
sometimes for a vehicle,
sometimes for use in gas mains.
And this one, this
is from Wikipedia,
but I couldn't resist it--
this is a North Korean
wood-powered truck.
But if you browse
around, there are
a lot of examples during
World War II where
these reactors were put on
cars that were then converted
to run on wood because
you couldn't get gasoline
in continental Europe
in World War II.
So it's not a novel technology.
It's not your first-choice
technology for vehicles,
but in places that have a lot
of wood and not much else,
it apparently is an interesting
and used technology.
There are plenty of vendors.
There plenty of examples.
So wood gasification-- but
I couldn't find anybody
who's doing coal commercially.
So that's unfinished item one.
Unfinished item two was CO2
emissions. [? Siddhartha ?]
asked about how fossil fuels
compare, and I kind of mumbled,
you will recall.
It turns out if you think
about it a little bit
beyond the mumble stage,
it's not a simple question.
You can do emissions per BTU.
You burn the stuff.
What do you get per BTU?
And that's the
carbon-hydrogen mix
in the fuel, which
varies slightly.
So you see coal has about
75% more emissions per BTU
than natural gas.
And petroleum-based fuels
are somewhere in between.
But of course, you don't
buy fuels for BTUs.
You buy fuels for some
purpose, some energy service.
You will recall, we don't
actually, most of us,
live for BTUs alone.
So home heating-- that
would be a good comparison,
but suppose you want
to do electricity.
Well, then you have to think
about how efficiently you
can use them in electricity.
You'll note that a gas
combined cycle plant is
more efficient than a
traditional coal/steam turbine
plant.
So that means in terms
of per kilowatt hour,
the advantage to
gas over coal grows.
And you think about
gas-powered automobiles
versus gasoline-powered
automobiles-- again,
there's a difference
in engine efficiency.
But even that, you've got
to think about the emissions
in producing it if you want
to do this kind of comparison.
And I haven't really
seen a good study
that lets you get to
that third level--
so good question.
Easy answer here, somewhat
easier answer, somewhat harder
answer here.
Can't answer that.
Any questions or comments
on either of these first two
topics?
OK, let me go to shale.
So the new technology
that really has changed--
but it isn't a new technology.
So let me be a little
bit clear about that.
But this is horizontal drilling
and hydraulic cracking,
called fracking.
So there are sort
of two pieces to it.
One is the ability to
drill deep into shale.
This little example shows
shale 7,000 feet deep,
in this case, the Marcellus.
I think this is from the
PennEnvironment thing.
And to do horizontal drilling--
horizontal drilling is not that
new, but it's relatively new--
and then to put down fluid,
which I'll talk about in a bit,
under pressure to make
cracks in the shale, which
permits gas and/or oil to
come back into the pipe.
Fracking, if you just drill
down and crack horizontally,
has been done for a long time.
Horizontal drilling
has been done
for a relatively long time.
Putting the two pieces together
has had a revolutionary impact.
I caution you,
"The Times" repeats
what the president said in his
State of the Union message,
which is, DOE started
all of this in the '80s.
This drives people in
the industry crazy.
They say, DOE invested a
few dollars in the '80s,
and then a whole bunch
of little US companies
have invested a lot since then
to actually make this work.
So big firms like Exxon did
not have this technology.
They're busy buying small firms.
Does this sound like a familiar
story from Don's discussion?
I mean, little guys experimented
and experimented and got it
to work.
So most of this fluid--
and we'll come back to
this-- is water and sand,
but there's other stuff.
And what other stuff varies
from producer to producer,
and is the source of a
good deal of controversy.
But it's mostly water and sand.
And what this does is it makes
it economical to extract gas
and oil from 7,000, 10,000-foot
underground shale deposits.
Now, it's not just that
it's possible-- it's cheap.
And cheap is the story.
Now, there's shale
around the world.
This is what one
installation looks like.
This would be called the "pad."
And what normally happens
is you drill multiple wells
from a single pad.
So they might go
underground this direction,
and this direction,
and whatever.
So you cover an area with
multiple wells from a pad.
When you pump the water down
under pressure, it comes back--
there's a shock.
And it comes back not only
with the stuff you put down,
but with stuff it picks up--
various underground minerals,
and chemicals, and occasionally
something's radioactive
or something's toxic.
It is then typically,
I assume, piped--
although I don't see pipes.
It's piped to a holding
pond, and from there it's
interesting-- in this picture,
it's being trucked away.
Sorry, the water is
stored in a pit or a pond,
and then taken to
a treatment plant.
What's often done
with it instead
is it's injected
underground in a deep well.
So the water either gets
treated out of this pond
or it gets, either
here or someplace else,
dumped back into
something that'll hold it
underground, some formation
where you might otherwise
store CO2, for instance.
But those are the
two possibilities.
So questions about the basic
story here, the basic process?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It
[? prevents ?] the ground
after you start to [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
the gas has come up with it,
so you're basically
taking the gas off,
and then you take the water.
Yeah, no, this is not full of
commercially recoverable gas.
Yeah, Jacob.
AUDIENCE: What kind
chemicals and fluids
do you typically pump?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, usually a surfactant
of some sort to reduce
surface tension, to make
it more easily penetrate.
In some cases, people have put
benzene and various petroleum
products down.
This causes a lot
of distress, as you
could imagine, but usually--
usually-- some surfactant
and other stuff.
For the little guys, this has
been sort of a secret sauce.
It's mostly water and sand.
And I'm not going to tell
you what the rest is, haha.
Well, what's missing here
is this might be an aquifer,
so there might be
groundwater issues.
And we're going to
talk about this--
usually not coming up
from 7,000 feet down.
The aquifers are higher.
But if the well's
integrity is breached,
stuff can come
out from the well.
And that happens.
OK, anything else?
All right, so
that's the picture.
So this process now makes
it economical to extract
oil and natural gas from shale.
Where is the shale?
The key thing is this gray bar.
The height is the amount
of shale gas recoverable.
The black is coalbed methane,
which is also doable.
But the new thing
is the gray bar.
And you will notice
we have a lot of it.
There's not that much in the
Middle East, some, presumably,
in Africa, but
little exploration,
some in Latin America, a lot of
it over here in Asia-Pacific,
which is mostly China.
So China appears to
have a lot of shale.
We got really lucky.
We have enormous amounts
of shale from which
this stuff is recoverable.
Australia often refers to
itself as "The Lucky Country."
In this one we got lucky.
Europe-- this, I
believe, is OECD Europe,
and that is mostly Poland,
which is starting to work on it.
So where is it in the US?
Well, the good news and the
bad news is, a lot of it
is near where demand is,
as opposed to, say, wind
or solar that tend to be in the
desert or in the high plains.
A big play here
is the Marcellus,
and that's New York, and
Pennsylvania, and Ohio,
and in this Eastern region.
That's enormous.
That's just an enormous
amount of recoverable gas.
The other play that
people talk about,
other plays that
are the Bakken up here,
mostly in North Dakota.
The Bakken has a
lot of oil that is
being recovered using this
same technique, as well as gas.
There are not a lot of
pipelines out of North Dakota,
and as we will see, that's a
problem, but oil you can move.
Oil's valuable enough.
You can find a way to move it.
The other places are the
Barnett, the Barnett shale,
a lot of which is-- oh, yeah,
there are a lot of people
up here in the Marcellus.
Some of this is rural.
Some of it's near urban areas.
You read that
PennEnvironment document.
They talk a lot about
schools, libraries, and stuff.
Down here in Texas,
a lot of it's
not near anything,
which is all good.
And in the Bakken, a lot
of it's not near anything.
I think the Eagle Ford
supposedly has a lot of oil.
But people have been doing
various kinds of fracking
in Texas, not
necessarily horizontal,
but vertical and
experimental, for a long time.
Nobody's drilled for
anything in the East
since the first Pennsylvania
oil field went dry
in the 19th century.
Well, I'll say a little more.
As you see, there
are plays elsewhere,
in Arkansas, for instance,
there's some action.
But this is the Marcellus, is
what people talk about a lot.
The Bakken there's a lot of
action, and then down in Texas,
with a little bit elsewhere,
little bit in California.
Colorado-- again, people have
been doing this in Colorado
for a while.
The reserves are smaller.
And I don't know much
about most of the others.
Comments or
reactions about this?
OK, so what's all this done?
Well, it's created a boom.
This is a map of
wells in Pennsylvania
through the end of 2010.
You see their trajectory--
27 wells drilled in 2010,
then 161, then 785, then 1445,
and 3,000 wells in the ground
producing by April of 2011,
with rapid permitting going on,
concentrated in a few areas.
Similar story elsewhere--
the Pennsylvania folks
just happened to have
provided a convenient map.
So you have a drilling boom
to get at this resource.
What's it done?
Well, it's depressed gas prices.
You may recall last time,
this is a Henry Hub price.
Last time, this graph
cut off about here.
This is the result.
This is the rest of it.
We're down in the neighborhood
of $2 per million BTUs, where
the normal price was
tending to be around 10,
eight, 10, was what people
thought was sort of normal.
And again, if you go
back to the Pennsylvania
figure, the drilling,
this is all since--
it just began in 2007.
There is no pre-2007
drilling in Pennsylvania,
and there are more than 3,000
wells, probably 4,000 by now,
producing.
So this has come on
very fast, very big,
and in parts of the
country where people live.
And it's depressed
the natural gas price.
To go to a question that
we discussed last time,
this is arguably old business,
but just to do an oil--
oh, yeah, people in the
business say what happened,
the reason we're at $2, is a
lot of people got very excited.
This happens in
businesses like this--
everybody drills a well.
All of a sudden, oh, my god,
we've drilled too many wells.
It's not profitable,
most people say,
to get at this gas at $2 a
million cubic BTU, but at $4
it is, and at $6 it is.
Somewhere in the
four to six range
is where people look for
a long-run equilibrium.
Drilling will slow
down for gas alone.
Demand will pull the price
up, blah, blah, blah.
So they look at the four
to six range, as opposed
to the eight to 10
to higher range,
as a place where gas
will settle down.
And there is a lot of it.
There's controversy
about how much there is.
So one thing it did was
to depress the gas price.
It drove an interesting
wedge between gas and oil.
So this is another one
of these comparisons.
If you just look at dollars
per BTU, which I caution
is kind of a crude measure,
because not all BTUs
are created equal.
Gasoline is better
for automobiles
because you can have a higher
energy density and a longer
range, and so forth, and it's
easier to transport per BTU.
So oil has a variety
of advantages,
but if you just look at BTUs,
then the conversion factor
is apparently 5.825, which
references tend to agree on.
So that means if gas
is $2 a million BTUs,
that translates into
$11.65 a barrel of oil.
But when gas hit $2 recently
over here, oil was over $100.
So that says in BTU terms,
the difference right
now is enormous.
If you can find a way to use
the gas BTUs and not oil BTUs,
it makes a big difference.
And it makes a difference
in a lot of settings.
I have a colleague--
I haven't seen the
paper, but he says
it's straightforward
that a natural gas
car dominates an electric car.
An all electric car, you've got
to have an expensive battery,
it has limited range, dadada,
you've got to plug it.
And natural gas,
you need a tank.
Engine is trivial to modify.
It doesn't cost much more,
and the range is also limited,
but it's about the same.
So why would you buy an electric
car when you can buy a gas car?
Well, we'll see.
They're not subsidized yet.
We'll see.
But anyway, this is a big deal.
Again, historically, there
are gaps between oil and gas.
They don't track precisely
because as I mentioned
last time, you don't really have
electric utilities substituting
every five minutes
between oil and gas.
But this is pretty
much unheard of.
That difference in price
per BTU is unheard of.
And it's opened in the
last couple of years.
So that has implications.
And again, "The Times" talks
about this without the picture.
The other thing it
does is look at this.
This is the Energy Information
Administration's Annual Energy
Outlook Early Release,
which came out
either January or February.
It says this is their
projection for future production
of natural gas.
This brown thing on
the top is shale.
I mean, look at
it-- there's nothing
going on here until about 2006,
2007, and then it explodes.
And by 2035, it
accounts for almost half
of total US production.
Previous work sort of focused on
these, just plain old gas, gas
that you get with
oil, coalbed methane--
steady decline, increase
in demand, lots of imports.
Tight gas, which is
related, is going up,
but shale gas is
projected to explode.
I happened to look because I was
updating last year's lecture,
and I had a graph
like this last year.
The graph last year showed--
this was, again, circa
last March or April--
it showed the US being a
net importer of natural gas
through 2035.
Again, this was a year ago.
It projected big increases
in shale, but not
enough to offset
demand, and said
we would be an
importer through 2035.
The current projection
a year later
is we'll be a net exporter
of liquefied gas by 2016.
We'll be a net
exporter overall--
pipeline and
liquefied-- by 2021.
That's in a year.
That's unheard of,
just to be clear.
That's a dramatic,
dramatic change.
I think when I taught
this two years ago,
I'm not sure we mentioned shale.
Anyway, the other thing is it
has had an impact also on oil.
If you look at oil,
US production of oil,
as we discussed early
in the semester,
has been in long-term decline.
in large part because of shale
and related developments,
they now project a pretty steady
increase in US production.
And this is not,
oh, my god, we've
authorized deepwater
drilling or oh, my god, we're
drilling the National Wildlife
Refuge on the North Slope.
This is under current policy.
This is under current policy
we will produce lots more oil.
OK, what's good about this?
What are the benefits?
We'll come to cost in a minute,
but is this a good thing?
Why is this a good thing?
Maxwell.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
It'll get us energy.
It'll move us toward
energy independence
if we use the natural
gas in transportation,
energy security, rather.
It'll affect our balance
of payments regardless.
But since most of our gas
imports are from Canada--
I know they're shaky up
there-- but to the extent
we use it in transportation, you
really get some energy security
benefits.
And let me just expand
on that a little bit,
because I know other
people want to talk.
One of the interesting things in
here that I hadn't focused on--
in "The Times," rather--
they talk about the
garbage truck market.
Garbage trucks are
perfect for this.
They're centrally fueled.
They're in use for
a few hours a day.
It's perfect.
And given the price difference,
the fuel price difference,
they said something like half
of garbage trucks sold now
are natural gas compatible.
A third of buses sold now
So you do expect a
reasonable amount of use
in transportation.
That'll reduce our imports,
improve the trade balance,
and improve energy security.
Anything else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Reduction
in emissions.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Reduction
in emissions, we'll get.
I want to come back to that
later because that's an issue.
You expect it to reduce
CO2 emissions as we
move from coal to natural gas.
There's some
controversy there and I
want to come back to that.
Jessica.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
resource, but you
have mostly infrastructure
layout [INAUDIBLE] so you're
taking [INAUDIBLE]
or it's easier,
there's less of a barrier
to entrance [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
You don't have
too much of a
chicken/egg problem
because you do have the pipeline
infrastructure in place--
not everywhere, and we'll
see that in a second.
You do have to put
in, if you're going
to do it in
transportation, you have
to put in refueling stations.
"The Times" argues that to do
it effectively and trucking--
forgetting about garbage
trucks and so forth
that you can pretty
much do now--
to do it for interstate
trucking you need, they said,
2,800 fueling stations on
the major truck routes.
And people are building them.
David.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You
expect the US industry
to be more competitive
because costs have come down.
There's the other interesting
thing that we tend to forget,
because we think of natural gas,
particularly in this class, as
mostly an energy source.
But it's a feedstock for a
variety of chemical processes.
And so a bunch of the industries
that use that as a feedstock--
plastics, importantly,
but others--
are moving back to the
US because it's so much
cheaper here than elsewhere.
So you're getting natural gas
based manufacturing moving
back, not only because
energy costs are
down but because
feedstock costs are down.
Anything else?
Ryan.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
American jobs.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Jobs--
I've got a great
graphic on that,
that I'll show you in a minute.
But that's normally
the first thing--
in Congress it's the
first thing they say--
this is jobs.
OK, I think we have most of
the benefits, but not all.
Anything else
anybody can think of?
Oh, sorry, yes, Kirsten.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
continue to explore
[INAUDIBLE] increases, so in
the future [INAUDIBLE] prices
to be less volatile
[INAUDIBLE] in the ground?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It
might be less volatile.
I think so.
But you still have this
short-run inelastic demand,
inelastic supply issue.
And a really cold winter
or really warm winter
can have an impact.
They do store gas, not
just in the big tanks
you see when you drive
south along the waterfront.
But it's stored in
underground caverns
and has been for a long time.
So you would hope that the
volatility will go down
because we're a little bit
out of the world market.
Yeah, didn't have that.
Anything else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Would that mean
money for the government
in terms of royalties?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It might
if it comes from federal lands.
Suppose it comes
from private lands.
I have friends who inherited
an otherwise useless ranch
in Texas and were told there's
natural gas under your land.
We'd like to drill.
They like that, because they
weren't going to live there.
In fact, nobody
was living there.
And they're happy
to cash that check
when it comes in every month.
So it's money for the
government in revenues,
depending on the royalties.
It could be money
from landowners.
And that's everything
except something
that we haven't talked
about and you might not
pick up until we've
talked about electricity.
And that is one of the
issues of bringing in wind
and solar is they vary and
they vary unpredictably.
So you need resources
that can respond to that.
I mean, storage would be swell.
Storage is the Holy Grail.
We don't have
storage economically.
So what you tend to use is
you tend to use gas turbines.
And gas turbines, if you recall
from-- not combined cycle,
but old gas turbines--
and on an earlier slide I
had the efficiency of those.
And it's not high,
but they're quick.
Well, this reduces the
running cost of the devices
you will use to use
more wind and solar,
and thus makes it
easier to integrate
wind and solar into the system.
Jacob, you had a point?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was just going
to say I hope you're going down
the path of it provides
baseload power for [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It
can provide baseload.
It provides, as we were
saying, lower emissions
baseload power, particularly
the combined cycle stuff.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] used
to turn on and off really
quickly when the
power demand spikes.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: And
you use the combined cycle
stuff for baseload.
You may or may not remember
the brief discussion
of combined cycle.
We'll probably come back to it.
But when we talked
about Hexion, I
mentioned there were two
sorts of technologies.
And the combined
cycle technology
is a generating technology,
not unrelated to what
was going on in Hexion, but
it's generating technology.
You use natural gas or oil
or whatever, but typically
natural gas, to
run a gas turbine.
The exhaust from the
gas turbine is hot.
You use the exhaust
from the gas turbine
to heat water to make steam
and you run a steam turbine--
hence combined cycle.
You can get a lot of efficiency
because you're not putting out
a high temperature exhaust.
You're not wasting that heat.
You use it.
And you can use it effectively
in a steam turbine.
So that's effective.
So the other thing
we didn't talk about
and that's because you don't own
homes, but if you own a home,
you'll have lower heating costs.
That bill that comes around
in the winter will be lower.
This is a good thing.
I just managed to
persuade my condo
to convert to gas from oil.
And electricity will be cheaper.
So for those of us who pay these
bills, that's a good thing.
We'll reduce gas and
probably oil imports.
It will reduce it because
there's more production
but also because you'll be
substituting gas for oil.
US manufacturing-- people get
very excited about a rebirth
of US manufacturing,
some of which
is driven by energy,
is driven by feedstock prices.
Easier to integrate
wind and solar, money
for people in rural
Texas for ranches they
had no intention of living on.
We're going to talk about--
I didn't underline
"some," but I probably
should have underlined "some."
Fewer neighbors in
rural Texas than,
say, in urban Pennsylvania--
that's an issue.
And of course, jobs.
These are pictures
of North Dakota.
And this is oil production
in North Dakota.
North Dakota is now the number
four oil-producing state
in the country from pretty
far down the league table.
And for the last three years, I
don't know what the early 2012
numbers are, but for
the last three years,
it's had the lowest unemployment
rate in the country.
So if you're from North
Dakota, this is fabulous stuff.
All of a sudden the
land is worth something.
All of a sudden there
are a lot of jobs.
And if you're running a
restaurant, all of a sudden
there are people who come in.
This is oil production.
This is gas production.
And this is an interesting
graph for a number of reasons.
You see what you
would expect, which
is natural gas
production goes way up.
But there aren't pipelines.
And this is the
percentage flared.
So "not marketed"
means "flared."
They're burning it.
So they're burning, depending
on the month, up to 40%,
typically above 30%
of the gas produced.
The money is in the oil.
They don't have enough pipeline
capacity to get the gas out
so they burn it,
which is a shame.
Somebody will build a pipeline.
That's money being burned.
OK, comments?
But there are issues.
You can find, and
I was going to try
to do it but my earlier attempts
to link YouTube videos didn't
work well.
But you can go to go to YouTube,
and most videos on fracking
look like this.
Somebody pours water,
lights a match, foomp.
And earthquakes-- there was
some recent press coverage
of fracking-related earthquakes.
So this is not a completely
benign technology.
I mean, neither were railroads.
Neither were coal-fired
power plants.
Neither are automobiles,
but it has issues.
Some of the issues--
they mostly come
from these features.
Some of the fluids
contain toxics,
some of the stuff that's
pumped down-- and again,
it varies from
player to player--
is toxic.
The water that
comes up is at least
as bad as the stuff that went
down, often quite a bit worse.
It's got whatever
junk it picked up
traveling through
thousands of feet of rock.
The wells go through
aquifers often.
You drill down.
You're drilling down
through an aquifer.
That's somebody's groundwater.
That's the well
water that's burning.
Methane has its own toxicities.
It is flammable,
per that picture.
And it is a greenhouse gas.
So the question that Philip
raised of lower emissions
gets to be a little complicated,
because methane leaks.
So these are the main issues.
Let me just walk through some
of the environmental problems.
First is groundwater
contamination--
not that big a deal in Texas,
big deal in Pennsylvania.
They actually have
water in Pennsylvania.
The best evidence I know
says that the problem comes
from the well bore,
from going down--
that it's very hard
for the gas to leak up
through 7,000 feet of
rock into the groundwater.
But in any case,
there are plenty
of examples where groundwater
has been contaminated.
There's also this
issue of wastewater,
the stuff that's coming back.
It's got all kinds
of junk in it.
If you don't inject it safely,
if the holding pond leaks,
if the treatment
isn't adequate, you
can have that as a
source of contamination.
There is nearby pollution.
There's all this junk.
You're running an industrial
operation-- again,
not necessarily so
terrible in Texas.
Do I have a picture?
No, I don't?
Not so terrible in some places,
but the methane will be out.
That's not nice stuff.
Various other toxic
things come out--
volatiles in the groundwater.
You get dust, and noise,
and a lot of traffic,
a lot of vehicle traffic.
You truck the gas out
typically, and find a pipeline.
You don't build a pipeline
to every well site.
So it's noisy, and
messy, and dirty.
Does that matter?
Well, in Pennsylvania
and New York,
there tend to be a
lot of people around.
In North Dakota and
Texas, not so many.
So whether these things are
important or not depends on A,
what the well does, and B,
what damages it inflicts.
I mean, my friends' ranch,
there's nobody for miles.
So yeah, there's dust, and
dirt, and traffic, and junk,
but it's polluting
the sagebrush.
In that PennEnvironment thing,
there are schools, hospitals
nearby.
Methane leakage-- let me
talk about methane leakage.
There was just a
piece in "Nature"
about methane leakage
from one field
that folks managed
to measure well.
And it was like--
not to make up a number-- like
6% of total production leaked.
Well, methane is
a greenhouse gas.
We talked about that earlier.
It has a relatively
short half life,
order of magnitude 10 years--
quicker than carbon dioxide
to come out of the atmosphere,
but while it's in
the atmosphere,
it's potent, more potent
than carbon dioxide per unit
of mass, or maybe per
mole, one way or the other.
In any case, this is
sort of a serious issue.
If you're going to produce this
stuff at scale for a while,
and dump a lot of methane
in the atmosphere,
you're going to have
climate implications.
There was a study that
said producing and using
natural gas via fracking is
worse for the climate than coal
on a lifecycle basis.
That study was
pretty badly flawed
because it assumed very
inefficient coal plants,
but if the methane
leakage is high enough,
that could be right.
And if you use the right
measure of climate damage, which
I think he used the wrong
measure of climate damage
as well.
But that's a serious issue.
Earthquakes-- "Another
Fracking Earthquake,"
from that t-shirt--
great t-shirt.
Again this year there
were discussions
of earthquakes in
northeastern Ohio,
thought to be associated
with basically dumping
all that water deep
underground, kind
of lubricating the formations.
An Ohio regulatory authority,
with a lot of consultation
with geologists, has
verified, they think,
that in fact, the fracking was
the cause of small earthquakes.
But small earthquakes
are earthquakes--
magnitude 3 kind of
earthquake, for those
who follow that sort of thing.
In Ohio, they've
responded by saying
it doesn't always do this.
It does it when it's
injected in certain ways
into certain formations.
And they have a set of
regulations for Ohio
that they think
will deal with this.
But it's an issue--
earthquakes, not
everybody's favorite.
How many people have been
through an earthquake?
Oh, yeah, from California?
Where?
All over.
AUDIENCE: Last summer here.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah,
there was a little one here.
OK, that's true, that's true.
That doesn't count.
If it's not magnitude 5 at
least, it doesn't count.
It's a weird feeling.
And in Ohio it doesn't
happen, but it does now.
It does now.
And this one is actually very
interesting if, as I hope
you did you looked at the
Jacoby et al. article.
Their argument is if
you look down the road,
and you're serious
about climate,
you will recall from our
difficult negotiations
the world's going to
need big reductions.
And you can't get
the big reductions
unless you can figure
out some magical way
to do transportation.
But you're not going to get
the big reductions unless you
get the carbon emissions from
the electric power sector way
down.
Natural gas doesn't
do that for you.
It gets it down,
but not way down.
But if natural gas
is cheap, then you
don't build a nuclear
plant, and you
don't fool around with
nuclear technology
because it's so noncompetitive.
And wind and solar require
bigger subsidies to compete.
And so the argument is it's
quite possible that cheap shale
gas will slow the development
of very low-carbon technologies,
and thus be a bridge to nowhere.
We will easily lower the carbon
content of the electric power
system, and heating,
and other things.
But after a while, we won't
be able to go any farther,
because we won't have
the technologies we need,
because they will have been
non-competitive all along,
and been very expensive
in subsidy terms.
And so this could easily
be a bridge to nowhere
that stops progress on
climate after a while.
That's why it's a
complicated question.
Short term, yeah, unless
you get a lot of leakage,
but the long-term
question's really hard.
What's it mean for
wind, solar, nuclear,
or other carbon-free
technologies?
The European Union,
I learned on Monday,
has a formal plan to
have zero carbon dioxide
emissions from its electric
power sector by 2050--
zero.
And as the presenter said, we
in Europe do a lot of talking.
But if you do a
projection of what
it takes to get 80% of
reduction in greenhouse gas
emissions, boy, you better
be pretty low carbon.
And natural gas won't
get you there no matter
how cheap it is.
What's the policy [INAUDIBLE]?
Questions on any of this?
Yeah, Max.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
wind, solar, nuclear
are fairly not competitive
right now, [INAUDIBLE]
still develop the technology.
So why would we keep
developing [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, wind and solar
are being driven by
subsidies, and those subsidies
get to be more expensive as the
alternative gets to be cheaper.
So the argument is
yeah, you could,
but if you were starting
a wind turbine business,
you'd have to be really sure
of the subsidies or pretty sure
that you can get the cost
down so you won't need them.
The lower the cost of gas
is, the harder that second
is to be sure of.
And the lower the cost
of gas is, in a way,
the first gets shaky because
it becomes hard politically
to justify subsidizing
wind and solar
when we're moving into gas
and emissions are going down
and we're all swell.
Nuclear, I think, is going
to be hit the hardest.
Well, we may talk about nuclear.
And we'll hear about nuclear
from some of your papers.
So I'm looking
forward to learning.
But I think what
people do tend to say
is with gas at these
prices, even forget $2
but $4, boy, is a nuclear
plant out of the money.
And if you don't
build them, it's
hard to really prove
out the technology.
There's all these
fabulous designs
for intrinsically safe,
small-scale nuclear plants,
but unless we build them,
we're not going to know.
And building them gets to be
a more expensive proposition.
So it's hard to do
that nuclear stuff,
because you really
need to do it at scale.
That means somebody's got
to bear the commercial risk,
and the commercial risk
gets bigger with cheap gas.
So I think that's
the basic issue.
I mean, the government
could say, look,
I think this is so important
we're going to keep doing it.
The Europeans might.
I worry about us, and we'll
see about the Europeans.
We'll see about the Europeans.
Anything else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does it matter also,
though, if, in a few years,
we'll have some sort of carbon
tax or something like that?
Because then you
would start arguing
that whatever emits carbon
will become less competitive.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
I mean, with a
serious carbon tax--
again, cheap shale,
cheap gas, the advantage
of renewables over
gas-fired power
goes down with the price of
gas, given any carbon tax.
You're right, the carbon
tax widens the gap.
Cheap gas narrows it, so
you need a bigger carbon tax
to have the same differential.
I mean, we all say,
of course, we're
going to have a carbon
tax at some point.
We have to have a carbon
I know people who have been
saying that for 20 years.
So I would love
to be young enough
to have the feeling that of
course it'll happen soon.
But I've watched it
not happen for so long.
And I've watched the Republican
Party harden against climate
so firmly that we'll see.
It may take-- those
of us in the area
speculate from time to time that
it's going to take something
like an ozone hole.
You recall or you
may not recall.
What led to the
Montreal Protocol
wasn't all the
brilliant chemical
work done, a lot of it here
at MIT that won a Nobel Prize.
It was the opening of the ozone
hole over the Antarctic, such
an image.
There's a hole in the ozone?
Most of us didn't know there
was ozone to have a hole in.
But there's a hole in
the ozone, and it's
letting in all these harmful
rays, and it's getting bigger.
That was pretty dramatic.
Having the Arctic be
ice-free maybe-- maybe
that'll be dramatic,
but we don't see that.
Ozone hole, you go out,
and you get a suntan,
and your risk of
skin cancer goes up.
Well, that kind of comes home.
There aren't any
more polar bears?
Well, that's too bad,
but I can go to the zoo.
So I don't know what
on the climate side--
I love polar bears.
Please don't quote me.
They're "charismatic
megafauna," as the phrase goes.
It may well take
something like that.
Anyway, anything else before
I go to the policy arena?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are the big
players large companies
or small [INAUDIBLE]?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: In
terms of this industry?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like
Chevron [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
The big companies
have bought small companies
to get the technology.
So the people who
were big gas producers
are big gas producers.
Again, there are
still small players.
There are still small players.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] direct
a little R&D money that way.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
I don't know.
I don't have the sense--
I could be wrong, but
I don't have the--
and we do sort of
see these folks
when they come to the Energy
Initiative to fund research.
So we get some sense of
what at least some of them
are interested in.
I hear a lot more
interest in finding
technologies than
extraction technologies,
3D seismic underground
mapping, improvements there,
rather than better drilling.
It's a young technology, but
it seems surprisingly mature.
Nobody says, "If only
we could do this."
The one issue that
people talk about,
and "The Times" mentions it a
little bit, is the technology
was aimed at gas and it's
not yet tuned for oil.
And there are places
where there's oil,
but they're getting a ton
of oil out of North Dakota,
so it's not too badly tuned.
So this particular
technology doesn't
seem to be a huge R&D target.
At least that's my sense.
It's very deep shale.
The stuff that would help you
figure out where the gas is
seems to be higher
on their wish list
than techniques to get it out.
If they can find it, they
can go down 10,000 feet,
drill sideways, break the
shale, and get the gas
out, which is pretty amazing.
The policy arena-- so the
PennEnvironment report
is pretty good on this.
It's a bit of an advocacy
piece, but it's pretty good.
You would normally think that
the air stuff would be EPA,
the air pollution
issues I talked about.
There is a Safe
Drinking Water Act
that you would think
would cover stuff
that would affect the aquifer.
And indeed, it does
in a lot of areas.
But there are exemptions to
a lot of federal legislation,
put in place quietly in
the middle of the night,
that means there's
relatively little EPA can do.
It can set some standards
for local air emissions.
And it's doing that
for methane emissions.
It will probably have
regs on methane leakage.
But the water side is
pretty limited by law.
I mean, it covers a lot of
stuff that pollutes aquifers.
It can't get at this.
And even if it
set the standards,
the enforcement would
be at the state level.
And if you think about it,
this is not easy enforcement.
I showed you 2,400 wells
in Pennsylvania-- lots
more coming.
How many inspectors do you
think the State of Pennsylvania
has to inspect
natural gas wells?
Well, they haven't
had any natural gas
drilling in
Pennsylvania or drilling
for anything in Pennsylvania.
So they probably started
out with, let's say zero.
And maybe they have a few if
their budget's been generous.
So enforcement is a state issue.
The rules about the
fluids are state issues.
EPA can't control that.
Rules for that well,
the bore, how well it's
sealed, how thick the concrete
is, what, kind of concrete
all of the stuff that gets you
down below the aquifer and that
has to be inspected--
that's the state.
The experience and attitudes
vary enormously among states.
New York, as I'll mention in
more detail, has a moratorium.
You cannot do this in
the State of New York--
full stop, done.
Pennsylvania is
letting people drill.
Does Pennsylvania
have expertise?
Does Pennsylvania have
an adequate budget?
Does Pennsylvania
have adequate laws?
The PennEnvironment
report suggests not.
Others may disagree.
I don't know enough
to have a view.
Texas does oil and gas.
They've been drilling
and fracking in Texas
for a long time--
not at this scale.
And Texas also has a lot of
rural areas, where it's dusty,
and it's dirty, and
it's I don't care.
Nobody lives here.
It's a job.
There are jobs.
That's fabulous.
Some states are revving up.
There's a lot of
industry interest.
Texas is now requiring
fluid disclosure.
I think others are.
There's an interesting
industry split.
The small guys
oppose regulation.
The small guys say, I don't want
to tell you what my fluid is.
I don't want to be inspected.
I'm doing a good job.
Leave me alone.
I'm just a little guy.
You talk to people from
Exxon, and people from Exxon,
and Chevron, and those guys
say, we need regulation.
This is anti-stereotype,
and it's worth
thinking about
because we'll come
to public policy
in a little while.
They want regulation.
Why do they want regulation?
They don't want to see a lot of
those videos of drinking water
burning.
They don't want a lot of states
to do what New York has done
and say, you can't drill here.
So the big guys think,
OK, it adds $1 or $2
per million cubic feet, to
control methane emissions,
to inspect the wellbore, to
limit the fracking fluids,
to disclose everything. $1
is nothing to the big guys.
$1 might be something
to the little guys.
The big guys are
afraid of a backlash.
The big guys are afraid,
and you hear them say this
after about two drinks.
This industry could go to
the way of nuclear power.
The public could be so
fed up with earthquakes,
and groundwater pollution,
and burning water coming out
of faucets, that
we get shut down.
And the country that could have
all this abundant, relatively
clean energy won't get it.
So the big guys are in favor
of sensible regulation.
There's a lot of industry
best-practice activity.
There's a lot of work by
the big guys with the states
to avoid a backlash.
Please impose reasonable
costs on this industry
we will still be cheap.
Don't shut it down.
An awful lot in the
environment community
think state
regulation can't work.
Pennsylvania's going to
regulate natural gas drilling?
They haven't seen a
well for 100 years.
What?
So they say it's
hard to enforce.
You're going to inspect every
well as it's being drilled.
You've got to monitor
the quality of concrete.
This is a serious
enforcement problem.
They're all over the landscape.
You can't do it.
Yes, in principle, regulation
might make this safe,
and so forth, and clean,
but you can't do it.
So you should just kill it.
Just kill it.
Again, if you
Google fracking on--
if you look at Google Images
and call for fracking,
you will get posters
and rallies galore--
ban it, ban it, ban it.
Stop fracking in Ohio.
Where else do you see a lot of--
it's banned in New York.
It's banned in France.
It's banned in at
least one German state.
And there are debates
in lots of other places
that say basically,
it's a moratorium.
If you can prove it's clean
and safe, we'll let it go on.
In North Dakota, it's jobs.
In Texas, it's we know this
and nobody lives out there
on those ranches anyway.
In New York, this is New York.
People live here.
Pennsylvania, people live here.
Yeah, Jessica.
AUDIENCE: How long could they go
using the natural gas reserves?
[INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: The ones
we have now, the shale gas?
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Hard to know--
what we're getting are estimates
of probably recoverable
reserves.
Proved reserves are much
lower, but estimates
are hundreds of years.
It's just a lot of
gas at low cost.
So what that thought leads to,
and the fact that it's cheap
leads to, it may be
impossible to kill
because the economic benefits
are so large that politically
it may be hard to kill.
But suppose everybody
in Pennsylvania
has their water burn
when it comes out of the.
Tap will New York
drop its moratorium?
Probably not.
Will Ohio impose a moratorium?
Probably.
So if you can't make it safe--
what's a little burning water?
I mean it's things.
But anyway, think about the
stuff we breathe every day.
But that's dramatic.
That's a YouTube video.
The PennEnvironment report has
sort of a balanced proposal.
It talks about
there's another part
of the environmental community.
It clearly couldn't be
killed in Pennsylvania.
It's 3,000 producing wells
and 10 a day being permitted.
What, are you kidding?
We're going to kill this?
I don't think so, not now.
So they say what you
need to do is eliminate
these federal
exemptions so EPA can
play a role for groundwater.
And they have a number of very
specific suggestions, which
I don't want to go in,
for tightening regulation
in Pennsylvania, like not
letting this stuff happen
near a school or near a hospital
just because there is increased
local pollution, no
matter what you do,
and giving the agency
some money to enforce.
It's easy to write rules.
Enforcement takes people.
And then finally, that
lovely interview with Fred
Krupp from the
Environmental Defense Fund.
As we'll talk about later,
the Environmental Defense Fund
has played a very
interesting role historically
in making environmental
policy in this country,
to the extent possible,
economically sensible.
And Krupp argues you can't
do anything in Washington,
so to say the EPA
should play a role--
of course, it should, but
you can't get that passed.
You can't get
sensible legislation
passed in Washington.
You can't get those loopholes
closed, at least not now .
And you probably
shouldn't kill it
because the benefits
are so large.
I think underlying that
is a realist saying,
you probably can't kill it
because the economic benefits
are so large for so many people.
So there really isn't any choice
but to work with the states.
Encourage the states
to talk to each other.
Encourage the big producers
to work with industry.
So that's sort of the
policy environment, I think.
Reactions?
Comments?
Anything?
OK, let me throw the floor open.
Suppose we were lucky
enough or unfortunate enough
to have shale in Massachusetts.
You're an MIT students.
You can march on
the State House.
You can get TV time.
You can make noise.
What do you do?
Drill, baby, drill--
we need the jobs.
We need the benefits.
Let's be real.
Let's make it hard.
It's not under Boston.
That would be too easy.
They're never going
to drill under Paris.
But suppose the shale
is in the western part
of the state, which has
been chronically depressed.
Suppose that's
where the shale is,
the western part, not
the Berkshires, kind
of central Massachusetts.
Pittsfield, has anybody
been to Pittsfield?
You've been to
Pittsfield, all right.
Are you from Pittsfield?
AUDIENCE: It's near Tanglewood.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
It is near Tanglewood.
Tanglewood is nice.
Pittsfield, well, MASS
MoCA, but otherwise
been depressed for a long time.
We've got shale in Pittsfield,
in the central part
of Massachusetts where
there are no jobs,
and you're going to
march on the State House.
Alex, was that your hand I saw?
AUDIENCE: I was
going to say, I think
if there is a way to do it
safely, if they can figure out
how to do it so your
faucet isn't burning,
then I think it
would be [INAUDIBLE]..
But otherwise, I
don't think it's worth
it if you're causing more
problems to all the people
who live there.
Because there are a lot
of people in [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Even in Pittsfield.
So would you
advocate a moratorium
until we know for sure
how to do it safely?
AUDIENCE: I'd advocate
for regulations.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Are we
sure we know how to regulate?
AUDIENCE: No.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: No.
OK, but you would say
at the very least,
the state ought to
acquire some expertise.
We ought to have
a legal framework.
I mean, nobody's
drilled for anything
but water in
Massachusetts ever, so we
don't have anybody who
knows about deep wells
or groundwater conta-- well,
we know about groundwater
contamination.
OK, anybody else?
Arianna.
AUDIENCE: My parents have a
house in upstate [INAUDIBLE]
New York.
And a couple of years
ago, actually, our town
exploded the
anti-fracking [INAUDIBLE]..
We were on literally
everyone's yard.
And I think that
even though there
are a lot of large-scale
benefits, in the end,
I think it's great
to do in Texas
and places where people
don't really live.
But there is a large segment
of not in my backyard.
And we like our house,
and primary residence
in New York City.
Part of it, I know, is
that it's nicer and clean.
The air is clean, and getting
to spend some time with nature,
I guess.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I hope
you have some nature up there.
Yeah
AUDIENCE: Lots of trees.
But the idea it's great if
energy prices fall, but I
don't want it at my expense.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So you'd advocate,
if we can translate to western
Massachusetts, which isn't
that dissimilar, you'd say, no.
No, thank you.
They're doing it
in Texas, they're
doing it in North Dakota.
The people in Pennsylvania may
or may not have made a mistake,
but we're not going
to do it, full stop.
OK.
AUDIENCE: I would
also say, why would--
if you're [INAUDIBLE] or whoever
has a significant population
and has no experience
with it, why
be in a hurry to go ahead
and drill everything and not
just wait to see some
sort of regulations?
I mean, to have
a clear framework
of what you should regulate,
and how you should do it,
and what are the
consequences, and all that.
So like North Dakota and
Texas have a smaller, lower
population density.
Figure out the hard
stuff, and then
figure out if you want to do it
or not in a few years when you
know what the consequences are.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Of course, we
may not be happy with a
regime that would make
them unhappy in North Dakota.
Because they're desperate
for jobs and we're
not that desperate.
So they might be willing
to deal with that
to accept environmental
harms that we wouldn't like.
So you wouldn't just want
to follow them, necessarily.
Julian.
AUDIENCE: So I'm going
to agree with Alex
for the most part,
in that regulation
is needed to some extent.
It is needed to
keep things safe.
But realistically,
you're going to have
to work very, very hard to keep
people's hands off of money
sitting underground.
I'm from Santa Barbara, and--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You can
see the oil out there, can you?
AUDIENCE: You can see 13
oil rigs from my house.
And there is a very, very, very
strong environmental movement.
It's California, blue Democrat
as hard as you can go,
pretty much.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You
do have some Republicans
in Santa Barbara.
AUDIENCE: We do, but
it is quite blue.
It is quite, quite blue.
And still people drill for oil.
You can see the
oil rigs out there.
There are even pumps
on land and whatnot.
And it's kind of
a tough argument
to go against it economically.
I mean, when you can say that
OK, these people might have
some bad health effects
from fracking and whatnot,
but if they can't afford
health care anyway,
then what's the
difference, really?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
we have universal health care
in Massachusetts, to a
pretty good approximation.
So we're OK here.
So we may as well just
drill because everybody
can get health care?
AUDIENCE: Well-- like if
someone can't afford something,
the economic benefits--
I mean, not necessarily in
Massachusetts exclusively,
but let's say in another
state which doesn't
have universal health care.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Let's say.
AUDIENCE: That
argument could be--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Connecticut
or western Connecticut,
Rhode Island, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I mean, there are
economic benefits, which can
in turn have other benefits.
And yes, there should
definitely be regulation,
but the argument to say,
no, we should absolutely not
touch this stuff
that's under the ground
is going to be extremely,
extremely hard, especially when
you go against probably
all the lobbyists from X
different firms which
are for this measure.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: And all
the mayors of depressed towns
who say, we need jobs.
We need jobs.
[INAUDIBLE],, you're going
to agree or disagree?
AUDIENCE: Disagree, actually.
Because when we had the
climate negotiations,
we were talking
about how urgent it
is to start taking
action to reduce
the CO2 emissions [INAUDIBLE].
So if you start
using this method,
and many studies
shows that it might
have very bad effects on the
environment, and in 10 years
we will see what are the bad
effects that this method had,
it's going to be
like 2022 and then
we start discussing again how
to reduce greenhouse emissions.
I think it's going to
be too late by then.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So you'd say no.
AUDIENCE: We don't have room
for any more mistakes anywhere.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Or let
them make the mistakes in North
Dakota and not nationwide.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --everyone.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Nobody
in here is from North Dakota,
as I recall.
I can insult North Dakota.
Get out of town.
David.
AUDIENCE: I think from an
environmental perspective,
even if you didn't
know it's 100% clean
and no methane, no
water caught on fire,
it's still a terrible
thing for carbon emissions.
Because your actions for
decreasing your heating bill
or insulating your house
so it's more efficient
and so you don't
need as much heat,
or using cheap
natural gas but then
to continue having a
really inefficient house
and leaking heat everywhere.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So
you're troubled by the bridge
to nowhere argument.
And you'd say, unless
we actually can fit this
into a climate policy--
which it could be if it
were part of a carbon tax,
use this for a
while, get off it--
would you be
comfortable with that?
Or you just say no.
AUDIENCE: I say
environmentally that's--
yeah.
Or you could use--
if the costs are so low, you
can have a very high carbon tax,
and use that money to perhaps
support solar or nuclear
or whatever.
But I think economically,
you can't make that argument.
You have to give people jobs
and environmental arguments
are going to get
legislation passed.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So you're saying
you'd march on the State
House, and you'd say,
"Only with a carbon tax,"
and you'd count on losing.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
No, no, I mean, hey--
you fight the good fight.
AUDIENCE: Jobs are not going
to part of the environment.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah,
you've actually been patient.
AUDIENCE: So I
would say that this
is an opportunity
for Massachusetts
to help take the lead a
relatively new industry.
And I don't think that
people will pass that up.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So you think no matter
what we say in here,
and what you guys
do when you march on the
capitol, we're going to drill.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
But New York
didn't, maybe because of all
those signs in Arianna's town.
Maybe Arianna's town
shut down New York.
And there are a lot of people in
upstate New York who need jobs.
There are a lot of
depressed towns up there.
landowners up there
who would love to
lease for drilling.
But they managed
to shut it down.
We're going to talk about that.
But you want to go one.
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah, I was just
saying I'm from South Dakota,
so I'm kind of jealous.
[INAUDIBLE] if you
look at that map,
basically, took a huge loop
right around South Dakota.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
Well, my guess is there are
people from some South Dakota
towns who are now
living in North Dakota.
North Dakota was going to
change the name of its state
to "Dakota" to avoid the "North"
for a while, but Matthew.
AUDIENCE: I just think
the economic benefit
is too big to pass up.
And if it was a serious
environmental concern,
it'll become more apparent.
It'll be accelerated
to regulation
if we allow it to
happen more here.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So you
think it's going to happen.
We're going to see
environmental concerns.
What the big guys
are worried about
is weak regulation, leads
to environmental disasters,
leads to a nationwide
moratorium.
Whatever happened in New York
could happen nationwide, maybe.
Maybe not in North Dakota,
but that's their concern.
And you're saying
we should run that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I mean, I think if they
realize the economic benefit
in the beginning,
they're not going
to solve it immediate--
like, altogether, they're
going to provide
some regulation.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, there's
a lot of work doing regulation.
Again, it varies state
to state, but OK.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think there's a
two-part argument for doing it,
but doing it on a limited
scale, versus like you said,
there's kind of an oversupply
of gas at the moment.
And the technology
being relatively new,
it's relatively
expensive, so you're
buying high and selling low.
But it is important
to start getting
some kind of understanding
of the drilling process.
Because from what I
understand, the effects
are different from place
to place because what's
in the shale is different.
So what works--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
And what's on the way
down, and the differences.
AUDIENCE: --in the Dakotas
is different from what
maybe works in
Massachusetts, but it's
different compositions.
So I would argue for
doing a limited roll-out.
You don't do it five
miles from town,
you do it 40 miles from town.
And you don't
authorize 3,000 wells,
you authorize 30 and
see what happens.
Hopefully, if there
is an earthquake.
You can figure out what's going
on before people freak out
and shut down the whole state.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So that's interesting.
And I hadn't heard
that proposal before,
which is what makes
it interesting.
So you'd say, we're
Massachusetts.
We haven't done this before.
We're going to hire some
people with expertise,
but the ones in Texas who
know what they're doing
are mostly staying in Texas.
So we can't effectively
regulate 300 wells.
Let's authorize 30, and let's
watch them closely, and see
what we can learn.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And once the market
stabilizes, then you
can start pumping more.
And then you'll
have a nice boom,
hopefully using cheaper
technology that's
more developed and
at a higher price.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Interesting.
Yeah, I hadn't heard that.
OK.
Marie, you had a--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
just wanted to mention
that I think there has been some
somewhat successful regulation
on this, as in Lebanon, Texas,
is going to make [INAUDIBLE]
long time, a lot of
regulation around this area.
And the Barnett
Shale is actually
right over the Dallas/Fort
Worth Metroplex,
so it is really in
an urban location,
and they're drilling
all around that.
And it's just a place where
it has been well regulated,
and [INAUDIBLE]
follow their example.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah,
I mean, Texas, for instance,
in the Bipartisan
Policy Center thing,
seems to have been the first
state to basically require
disclosure of
fracking fluids, which
is sort of a first
natural step, I think.
And then you limit
things that can go down.
So maybe we can
copy Texas, but they
have been drilling
in the Barnett
for a while with
different technologies.
OK, and we will all wear hats.
That'll be great.
Sam.
AUDIENCE: First, as
far as Massachusetts,
I think if you're trying
to sell that proposal,
you might have a hard time
selling it to Massachusettsians
copying Texas, just
from like association,
people of Massachusetts
aren't huge fans of Texas.
I think--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You didn't
like Rick Perry's campaign?
Never mind.
AUDIENCE: But I did think
politically it would
be hard to sell.
Just in Massachusetts, people
are pretty environmentally
conscious.
And I think all it would take
is, like, one anecdote of oh,
my cousin in Ohio,
he had an earthquake
or his water is on fire--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So you think.
AUDIENCE: We like to overreact.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: The
political system overreacts.
So your view is, even
though Arianna's community
managed to shut down
the State of New York--
it's a pretty blue state, but
probably less environmentally
conscious than this one--
it would be tough to do here.
So what would you
advocate instead,
when you march on
the State Capitol?
AUDIENCE: Take the money and
invest in green technology
instead.
I think the path to nowhere
argument is pretty good,
as well.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
It's pretty interesting.
Yeah.
What about the "go
slow" approach?
AUDIENCE: I think
once you start down
that, it's going to be
pretty hard to stop.
I mean, once you start
putting in a few,
it is going to produce cheap
energy, but it doesn't really--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
And jobs, and jobs.
We'll put them in Pittsfield
or someplace like Pittsfield.
Yeah, Max.
AUDIENCE: I think the
biggest [INAUDIBLE] of this
is [INAUDIBLE] take
a lot of transparency
in the industry, the argument
that the chemicals are
proprietary, so
[INAUDIBLE] nobody really
has a good way of measuring how
much methane exactly is being
released in the environment.
And so we know the
economic benefits,
but we don't know
the environmental
[? measurements ?] of it.
And that's the biggest
problem with regulating.
Even if you did
a few small wells
before you moved into the
large scale, [INAUDIBLE]
regulating them, just because
of those loopholes and the fact
that there's no real
metric for how much damage
it's actually doing.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
There are techniques--
not great techniques,
but there are
techniques-- that can measure
methane emissions, methane
leakage.
It isn't trivial.
That piece in "Nature"
talked about how
they managed to measure
methane emissions
from one area, methane leakage.
But it's naturally
tricky, because it
comes from lots of different
places and is dispersed.
You can, however, talk
about ceiling requirements
and how joints are done.
You could put in things.
It may be hard to
measure what happens,
but you could put in
place regulation that
will reduce it,
whether it'll reduce it
enough, blah, blah, blah.
So you're saying-- so where
would you go when you march?
AUDIENCE: I would advocate for
it because [INAUDIBLE] there,
but demand transparency
from the firms that
are doing it to kind of
[INAUDIBLE] and having them
[INAUDIBLE] or at least come
up with some sort of metric
to [INAUDIBLE] how much
damage they're actually doing.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah, so you
might work on the development
of measurement methods
for methane, for instance, and
require them to implement them,
and so on, and so forth.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Given how afraid
some of the companies
are of backlash, especially
if you invite the bigger ones,
perhaps it isn't as slippery
a slope [INAUDIBLE]..
And if you build 30
and they do well,
and regulation starts
loosening, almost immediately
if anything does
go wrong, that's
the whole thing gets shut down.
The companies are
quite incentivized,
in a similar way to
nuclear companies,
to keep a completely
white sheet.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
The big guys are.
AUDIENCE: Precisely, and so--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: The little
guys are the potential trouble
spots.
AUDIENCE: And so if
you have 30, given
that you have some data from
the big guys in other states,
it would make sense if
you have 30 test cases,
and then for the
future cases to be
from those people that have
at least some prior history.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Oh, that's interesting.
So you'd look at their
regulatory history elsewhere,
and you would try,
in Massachusetts,
not to let people who
have bad records drill.
AUDIENCE: And then you
have the comparative issues
between what they do in
Massachusetts versus North
Dakota [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Just from an
environmental perspective,
isn't it better to
drill in Massachusetts,
in the sense that it's going
to be happening [INAUDIBLE],,
so you could argue that it
happened in Massachusetts,
and the type of
population that you have
and the quality of
engineers, you're
going to set industry best
practices in Massachusetts,
which are going to be copied
in North Dakota, then.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Maybe.
The counter-argument is that
because of our population
density, the
potential for damage
is higher, potential for
environmental damage.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah, no.
So you're saying
you'd do it here,
but you would allocate
state resources,
and of course you'd beg
for federal resources,
to improve best practices, to
improve measurement methods.
One of the things that the
Secretary of Energy Advisory
Board, the SEAB report that's
cited in a couple of places,
stressed--
they said the government
is lousy at this.
The big guys in the industry
are able to develop and improve
best practices.
They need to be
encouraged to do it.
The problem is once you come
up with a best practice,
it becomes a compulsory
practice, and so forth.
But that's another issue.
OK, I think we're out of time.
Have a great long weekend.
We will do
electricity next week.